thank you thank you Nika
good afternoon I'm speaking to you today
from Damascus
I'd like to start by offering my sincere
condolences to the Syrian people for the
enormous losses they have such thing
I have seen first on the devastating
impact of the earthquake and listen to
the stories of survivors
a girl who lost both her parents and
suffered a broken arm when their
six-story apartment building fell
notice just one example of an unfolding
tragedy that's affecting Millions
the compounding crisis of conflict
copied cholera economic Decline and now
the earthquake have taken an unbearable
code
I also offer my deep respect and
admiration to the survivors and
responders including our own who staff
I have been so impressed by the dignity
Faith and Hope expressed by so many
survivors and by the dedication of the
responders
who is with the Syrian people and with
the people of Turkey
National and international organizations
the neighbors mosques church and
Community groups are raising to provide
people with a place to sleep and feel
safe with food clean water and medical
care for injuries resulting from the
earthquake but also for other health
needs
at one of the shelters we visited
yesterday a mobile Health Clinic
supported by who Distributing medicines
to people who had come in for support
for a range of conditions
many people had headaches difficulty
sleeping and anxiety
who and other organizations have trained
Community workers to offer rapid mental
health support but much more is needed
in addition that nature is providing
medical supplies and working with
Partners to provide the specialized
Medical Care and so far we have
distributed 110 tons of medical
satellites to affected areas throughout
the Syrian Arab Republic a flight is
scheduled to reach Damascus tonight we
specialize in emergency Health steplines
which are invited for Frontline workers
as they manage casualties in addition
we're supporting search capacity or
Frontline specialized Medical Teams on
the morning of the earthquake wh
immediately accessed its pre-positioning
supplies in the Northwest and Aleppo
making treatment of major injuries
immediately possible after checking on
the welfare of their own families our
staff immediately went to warehouses to
start Distributing satellites to help
facilities who is working across all
affected areas and further scaling up
across the country including in the
Northwest who immediately made available
16 million dollars from the contingents
fund for emergencies for the response in
both the Syrian Arabic Republic and
protea
today we have launched an appeal for 43
million US dollars to support the
military response in both countries this
will increase but the magnitude of This
Disaster becomes even more clear
but we need to take the response to the
next level to reach all affected
populations in all areas we welcome the
easing of sanctions by the United States
of America
we welcome the recent blanket approval
by the government of the Syrian Republic
for the U.N for cross-line combos as
well as measures to increase coach board
their access we hope this continues
I'm waiting to move across lines to the
Northwest where we have been told the
impact is even worse earlier this
afternoon I met with this Excellency
president Assad who indicated he was
open to considering additional
cross-border access points for this
emergency
once again WTO is committed to
supporting the Syrian people now and in
the days weeks months and years ahead to
respond with disaster and to build a
stronger system for all syrians I thank
you